dans quelle société veut dire qu'on vit
dans une société qui accepte de prendre
des risques dans une société qui va vous
êtes pro sécuritaire et donc se
positionner en enlevant des libertés
c'est un vrai débat de société et juste
j'aimerais revenir sur quelques points
pour moi on n'a pas forcément protéger
les yeux on a cherché à protéger la vie
parce qu'on avait probablement peur
d'une mort et qu'on a peur de mourir et
on a peur aussi de vieillir donc la
question c'est est-ce qu'on a posé aux
plus âgés classement ehpad ou à domicile
la question de comment vous les tulipes
7 ce confinement comment veut-il vive le
poste confinement c'est aussi des sujets
pour mais un peu de côté aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'associations de retraités
s'arrête parce que les mesures sont trop
strictes pour pouvoir envisager des
dispensation des port du masque et
cetera donc comment on arrive à recréer
aussi des possibilités au même titre que
pour emmanuel et pour les jeunes qui ont
envie de circuler et bien les vieux
aussi ont envie de garder leur mobilité
et être dans l'espace public parce qu
ils le sont depuis de façon peu et de
plus enfin un visibiliser et genre
existe deux derniers éléments on parle
des vieux et des jeunes comme des
catégories homogènes
or on voit bien qu'ils ont des
différences à la fois de classe sociale
de genre de rapport à nos vulnérabilités
et au rapport au territoire et cetera
qui font que ces catégories sont
hétérogènes
est-ce que poser aussi juste emmanuel à
la fin c'est ce cet élément de
solidarité en effet nos politiques
publiques depuis 1945 ont été basées sur
de la solidarité entre les générations
où entre les classes sociales
est ce qu'il faut ou pas repenser des
modèles
c'est aussi j'irai une discussion à
avoir dans cette question de la société
dans laquelle on veut vivre aujourd'hui
sécurité liberté où les devises
[Musique]